[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce 21 novembre
c'est la Semaine européenne de la
réduction des déchets cet événement
sensibilise le grand public sur les bons
gestes à adopter chaque année en France
un habitant produit plus de 350 kg
d'orures ménagères ce soir direction Les
Mureaux pour visiter l'appartement zéro
déchet la Coupe du monde de football
vient de démarrer un rendez-vous que
beaucoup appel à boycotter en raison de
son bilan écologique et humain pour son
retour musical le rappeur curta c'est
d'ailleurs saisi du sujet et ligne
montée en revient sur son titre critique
il revient dans son titre critique Coupe
du Monde au Qatar sur cette compétition
et ce titre fait déjà le buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux rencontre et qu'il n'y a
pas que la Coupe du monde de football
dans l'actualité sportive les clubs
sportifs yvelinois et les sportifs
Yvelines étaient également sur le pont
ce week-end le détail dans cette édition
des résultats du troisième tour de la
coupe des Yvelines de football nous
prendrons également des nouvelles de
Muriel le Beauvillain en lice dans les
championnats du monde de culturisme
naturel
du footbal à suivre on verra avec vous
Michael el midro l'ensemble des
résultats sportifs ou est-ce qu'il
faudra aussi voir bonsoir les matchs des
Bleus pour cette coupe du monde de
football puisque quelques communes des
Yvelines diffusent ces rencontres et
avec vous également des invités tout à
l'heure sur la partie sport également on
va parler d'un tournoi de tennis
handisport qui se déroulera à
Feucherolles dans les Yvelines dans les
prochains jours de ce jeudi à ce
dimanche avec moi sur ce plateau avec
nous sur ce plateau de personnalité leur
Moreau qui est directrice du tournoi et
Jean-François Mettet qui est secrétaire
général au Comité des Yvelines vous
allez parler de quoi qu'est-ce que ça va
être le concept de l'événement c'est un
événement qui nous tient d'abord
beaucoup PACA donc merci de nous inviter
à en parler après avoir organisé un
tournoi national tennis fauteuil on se
lance dans l'étape supérieure tournoi
international qu'on appelle futur donc
c'est le premier grade dans les tournois
internationaux un tournoi qui va réunir
dans des tableaux de simples et doubles
voilà donc un bel événement sportif à
venir mais aussi un événement humain
parce que ça se passe un petit peu
différemment d'un tournoi valide donc
voilà donc c'est des beaux échanges dans
tous les sens du terme donc ce sera à
suivre tout à l'heure dans la partie
sport avec les résultats sportifs et
aussi on parlera de ce tournoi cette
semaine dans les Yvelines avec nous
également tout à l'heure en plateau mars
gorbenas qui est conseillère municipal
de La Verrière conserve communautaire
également de 50 ans en Yvelines elle
viendra nous parler du lancement du
réseau élu local c'est un réseau élu
avec un e un c'est au féminin un réseau
qui a pour ambition de promouvoir la
politisation le système politique la
politisation féminin on en parlera tout
à l'heure dans cette édition avec nous
également donc les journalistes de la
rédaction vous avez vu Michael il y a un
instant il y aura également Céline chart
dans un instant bonsoir Céline Charles
avec vous les informations du jour de
quoi parle-t-on aujourd'hui alors pour
débuter cette semaine on fera un point
sur l'affaire Samuel Patty avec de
nouveaux éléments on parlera également
du nouveau financement accordé au campus
de Versailles on fera aussi un petit
retour sur ce qui s'est passé dans les
Yvelines ce week-end nous voici le
programme de ce 7 8 mais avant de
débuter petit coup d'œil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
grisaille ce mardi dans les Yvelines
avec peut-être les villes d'Oudon et de
Rambouillet qui seront épargnés épargnés
par la pluie le matin il fera en moyenne
entre 6 et 16 degrés et 7 degrés 7
degrés le matin je suis un peu trop
optimiste quelques éclaircies peut-être
dans l'après-midi mais avec de la pluie
il fera à 10 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 9
degrés à Versailles ou dans et
Rambouillet ce mardi 22 novembre nous
fêterons les Cécile
mais avant la Sainte Cécile il y a
Céline Charles qui est avec nous en
plateau je vous le disais il y a un
instant pour les informations du jour et
on débute Céline avec du nouveau dans
l'affaire Samuel Paty c'est la une de
nos confrères du Parisien le journal
révèle les derniers investigations sur
l'assassinat du professeur
d'histoire-géographie Samuel Paty était
apeuré par l'ampleur et l'agressivité de
la polémique l'ancienne principale de
l'établissement en poste au moment de
l'attentat s'est exprimé le 11 janvier
dernier face au juge en de la faire
Patrice Karmous nous fait un petit point
sauvagement assassiné en 2020 à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine quelques jours
à peine avant sa mise à mort c'est le
Parisien qui révèle dans son édition de
l'indice et nouveaux éléments de
l'enquête tel qu'ils apparaissent dans
leur rapport des policiers nourrit de
témoignages inédits et de l'historique
des recherches effectuées par le
professeur quelques jours avant sa mort
plusieurs de ses collègues racontent
notamment l'état de stress et de tension
dans lequel il se trouvait pour leur 14
personnes complices d'abdoulah controv
parmi lesquels des collégiens qui ont
désigné Samuel Paty au tueur contre de
l'argent et le parent d'une élève
d'ailleurs absente du cours de Samuel
Paty ainsi qu'un militant islamiste figé
s responsable de la campagne de haine
contre l'enseignant sont mises en examen
mais ces nouveaux éléments qui ajoutent
comme l'écrivent les policiers que c'est
l'action combinée de ces protagonistes
impliqués à des degrés divers mais tous
indifférentes aux conséquences néfastes
de leurs actes qui aura conduit à
lassassinat ces nouveaux éléments donc
pourraient nourrir la plainte pour
non-existence à personne en danger et
non n'empêchement de crimes qu'on
déposer des membres de la famille de
Samuel Paty car c'est bien là que se
situe le fond de l'affaire Samuel Paty a
bénéficié de quelques soutien de ses
collègues mais pas de tous du soutien de
sa principale mais pas de toute la
hiérarchie de l'éducation nationale et
en tout cas il a été laissé seul sans
protection face à un déferlement de
haine qu'on a accusé à tort d'avoir
déclenché faire la lumière sur ces
manquements serait non seulement rendre
justice à Samuel Paty mais aider aussi
tous ses collègues qui se heurtent aux
atteintes de plus en plus répandues à la
laïcité
dans l'actualité également Céline le
campus de Versailles qui on le rappelle
est dédié au patrimoine et à l'artisanat
d'excellence va bénéficier d'un
financement c'est ce qu'on annoncé très
récemment en deux ministres et c'est
votre chiffre du jour oui Grégory un
financement de 5,6 millions d'euros
destinés au campus Versailles l'un des
70 lauréats retenus suite à l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt compétences et
métiers d'avenir Sylvie Retailleau
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche et Rima abdulm Malak
ministre de la Culture ont fait le
déplacement vendredi 18 novembre sur le
site le centre de formation pour les
métiers d'art et d'artisanat ce
financement devrait permettre
l'établissement de créer des formations
pour tous les âges écoutés le projet sur
cinq ans donc ils ont demandé par
exemple un million la première année un
million cinq donc ça s'échelonnent sur
cinq ans et sur les 5 ans ils vont être
aussi accompagnés ils vont y avoir une
évaluation du projet amis parcours une
évaluation du projet en fin de parcours
voilà donc c'est un accompagnement et
surtout la possibilité de réaliser un
projet qu'ils ont pensé conçu
accompagner
voilà pour ces propos et recueillis par
Régine ralechent un peu de culture à
présent ce week-end se tenait le salon
histoire de lire le rendez-vous des
passionnés d'histoire à Versailles et
oui cette année encore il se tenait dans
divers lieux à Versailles trois jours
d'échange de rencontre de dédicaces avec
de grands noms de la littérature ou de
l'histoire parmi les invités l'animateur
vedettes Stéphane Bern ou bien la Grande
Duchesse du Luxembourg auteur d'un
ouvrage en commun Mika et midoro l'a
rencontré
[Musique]
j'ai été invitée pour ce fameux Salon du
livre de Versailles qui attend de succès
chaque année et je suis très
reconnaissante à la Chambre de commerce
de me recevoir à cette occasion avec
tant de bienveillance et d'amitié
ne fait que fortifié nos liens
d'affection avec la France
je suis ravie d'être là pour présenter
avec Stéphane le livre qui a été écrit à
l'occasion de mes 40 ans de mariage et
donc Stéphane nous a aidé à écrire un
très beau livre dans lequel il est
question de de cette vie
hors du commun et des actions que j'ai
engagées
c'est une manière de montrer que
une institution comme la monarchie c'est
aussi une famille et une famille qui vit
au service de son pays mais que c'est
une famille comme les autres avec les
joies et les peines de toutes les
familles
il y a quelque chose de très spécial que
Stéphane nous a demandé de faire et
d'assez inédit c'est qu'il a demandé à
mon mari d'écrire comment lui a vécu ses
40 ans de mariage et à moins d'écrire
comment j'ai vécu mes 40 ans de mariage
et ça c'est le livre s'ouvre sur ces
deux témoignages ce qui est déjà je
trouve assez émouvant et original
[Musique]
ce samedi 19 novembre il y avait aussi
un spectacle caritatif l'Association
pour la Recherche sur la trisomie 21
organisée un rendez-vous culturel sur
scène la compagnie de danse regard en
ligne avec des artistes touchés par la
trisomie 21 on écoute le président de
l'association Jacques hostile au micro
de Mélanie poquet l'importance de cette
soirée c'est surtout de permettre aux
jeunes qui ont des handicaps cognitifs
de pouvoir s'exprimer sur sur scène
depuis 2019 ils ont pas eu de
spectacle et donc quelque part on
pourrait remettre à l'écrit
vous pouvez noter dans vos agendas que
l'association sera aussi présente les
deux trois et quatre décembre prochain
lors du marché de Noël de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à la Ferme du
Manet alors si vous cherchez des
couronnes de Noël ils pourront vous en
proposer pour terminer Céline deux
informations dont on va parler cette
semaine dont on parle même ce soir en
effet deux semaines nationales et
international à noter jusqu'au 27
novembre c'est la 11e édition de la
Semaine de l'industrie de nombreux
événements sont organisés partout en
France à destination déco gellégiens
lycéens apprenti et demandeurs d'emploi
autre semaine thématique plus
environnementale c'est la Semaine
européenne de la réduction des déchets
débuter le 19 novembre dernier l'édition
2022 et sur le thème du textile merci
Céline et si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'une information
d'un fait qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez
pas à le dire sur nos réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news et dans le
cadre de la Semaine européenne pour la
réduction des déchets justement l'office
de développement durable a ouvert un
appartement pédagogique zéro déchet
fabrication de lessive maison ou encore
de savon solide pour le soin du corps
durant toute cette semaine le public
peut visiter ce lieu pour recevoir de
précieux conseils et astuces visant à
réduire leur consommation de déchets le
reportage de Julien le roi stocker ses
aliments dans des bocaux en verre
composé ses épluchures de légumes ou
encore utiliser une brosse à dents en
bois l'office du développement durable à
aménagé un appartement pédagogique et
écologique de 100 mètres carrés aux
Mureaux objectifs permettre au public
une visite immersive pour promouvoir une
consommation plus durable faut savoir
qu'on est quand même à plus de 350 kg
par personne et par an de déchets et
donc là l'idée c'est justement de pas
culpabiliser le public mais de leur
donner des conseils des astuces un
public présent déjà sensible au sujet de
la consommation durable la période de
confinement liée au covid-19 a permis un
regain d'intérêt sur ces questions
environnementales tout ce qui est
produit d'entretien on fait aussi le
compost aussi on fait
on fait aussi attention aussi tout ce
qui est éclairage unitylle tout ce qui
est apparaît en veille on fait aussi
être aussi à l'économie d'eau nous
manques de consommation sont de plus en
plus
à l'achat à
consommer jeter alors qu'il faut essayer
d'avoir des nouveaux réflexes qui sont
plutôt
réparés réutiliser donner
faire maison aussi se mettre au
compostage permet jusqu'à 30% de
réduction de cette déchets organiques
une consommation plus responsable pour
une réduction des dépenses à travers des
gestes simples faire ces produits
ménagers maison passer au savon solide
ou
shampoing solide dans la salle de bain
ça va être des économies pour les
habitants organisé dans le cadre de la
Semaine européenne de la réduction des
déchets cet appartement pédagogique sera
ouvert jusqu'au 30 novembre au scolaire
et au grand public
aider la fin de ce 7 8 retrouver
quelques bons conseils pour réduire vos
déchets sur nos réseaux sociaux nos
différents réseaux sociaux autre
thématique mise à l'honneur cette
semaine du 21 au 27 novembre c'est la
11e édition de la Semaine de l'industrie
les acteurs de ce secteur d'activités
seront mises à l'honneur l'industrie qui
représente 13% du PIB de la France pour
parler de cet événement Nicolas dandry
est avec moi en plateau bonsoir de la
rédaction de TV 78 et vous étiez ce
matin sur le site Airbus defense and
space et taille en cours effectivement
Grégory a un site qui est spécialisé
dans le spatial et la défense et la
Semaine de l'Industrie 2022 a débuté
là-bas avec l'inauguration de Jean-Noël
Barrault ministre délégué en charge de
la transition numérique et des
télécommunications une inauguration en
présence de lycéens de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et de
Mantes-la-Jolie puis des étudiants de
l'ESTACA cette semaine de l'industrie
l'occasion de valoriser ce secteur
d'activité de sensibiliser aux métiers
industriels on écoute le ministre
Jean-Noël Barrault les métiers
industriels sont mal connues
ils ont une image qui ne correspond pas
à ce que c'est que la réalité de ces
métiers aujourd'hui ils ont beaucoup
changé ils ont intégré beaucoup de
numérique les machines à commande
numérique sur des chaînes qui sont
automatisées qui sont optimisés il y a
donc dans ces métiers beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses à trouver que ce soit
en matière de rémunération bien sûr mais
aussi en matière de sens et l'objectif
de cette semaine de l'industrie c'est
justement de les faire connaître avoir
ce moment où on met l'éclairage sur ces
nouveaux métiers pour donner envie aux
nouvelles générations et notamment aux
jeunes filles qui pour l'instant ne s'en
détourne en grande partie et bien d'y
rentrer et bien pour cette occasion les
dirigeants d'Airbus défunts and space
ont reçu les PME les start-up que le
avec Kiki le groupe industriel collabore
le ministre Jean Albao on a profité pour
échanger avec ces sociétés spécialisées
dans le domaine du numérique de la
cybersécurité ou encore de la défense ce
sont les principales activités d'Airbus
des fans and space et à ce propos je
vous propose d'écouter François Lombard
directeur de l'activité intelligence
Airbus des fins and space le site
d'Élancourt pour nous c'est vraiment le
site du numérique de défense vous allez
trouver en particulier les activités
stratégiques autour de la protection
cyber vous allez trouver des activités
qui vont tourner autour du support au
renseignement du numérique de défense
comme je mentionnais précédemment
beaucoup d'activités autour de la
connectivité c'est un site qui fournit
par exemple
des supports aux forces armées en termes
de connectivité quel que soit l'endroit
où elles sont dans le monde c'est aussi
le site qui protège et qui supportent la
connectivité de la de tout ce qui est
protection civile on a dans le site
d'Élancourt historiquement et pour les
pour les 10 années qui viennent la
responsabilité de la radio du futur et
je vous le disais au début il y a des
étudiants de l'ESTACA qui ont été
passionnés ils étaient présents sur le
site un groupe de 70 futurs ingénieurs
de l'école de Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui
ont pu découvrir les activités plus ou
moins sensibles d'Airbus defense and
space alors pourquoi plus ou moins
sensible parce que il y a des activités
qui sont classées secret défense et pour
certains c'était l'occasion d'avoir des
précisions sur le quotidien des
ingénieurs de ce groupe industriel on a
pu voir les les salles propres et donc
de voir concrètement où est-ce que sont
fabriqués les satellites dont nous parle
souvent en cours parce que nos
intervenants de course sont souvent des
gens d'Airbus et des travailleurs
d'Airbus et c'est intéressant même pour
notre projet professionnel de pouvoir se
projeter visuellement et dans quel style
de locaux ils sont les ingénieurs sont
accueillis parce que c'est en fait moi
je suis en 5e année donc c'est en fait
mon avenir dans un ou deux ans peut-être
on a discuté avec pas mal de startups et
on a bien vu que ce sont souvent des
ingénieurs ou des des gens issus de
métiers techniques qui ont décidé de
prendre en main leur propre entreprise
et de déposer des brevets éventuellement
pour créer de nouvelles technologies
donc c'est vrai que c'est ça reste
possible pour pour nous futurs
ingénieurs et très très enrichissant et
excitant je pense aussi
voilà pour le lancement de cette semaine
de l'industrie qui donc se déroule toute
cette semaine merci Nicolas pour ces
précisions je me tourne à présent vers
notre prochaine invité qui nous a
rejoint en plateau c'est Marcy gorbena
bonsoir vous êtes élus à la verrière
l'une des initiatrices du réseau dont je
parlais tout à l'heure et Luc local et
lui avec un e c'est au féminin et il est
lancé donc dans les Yvelines une
rencontre se déroulait ce matin à La
Verrière avec plusieurs élus notamment
de mères de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de
mer femme de 50 ans en Yvelines
Alexandra Rosetti pour la commune de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux Joséphine Colemann
berger pour la commune de plaisir et
donc pour préciser élu local c'est un
collectif qui a pour but de sensibiliser
la féminisation de la vie politique
aussi aider les femmes élues c'est un
réseau national c'est ça comment et
quand a-t-il été créé ce réseau tout
d'abord je vous dis MERCI MERCI de
recevoir sur votre antenne pour parler
de ce réseau c'est un réseau de femmes
politiques élu local tout à fait ce
réseau déjà national donc il est déjà
sur tous les temps du territoire ça a
été créé par Julia Mozin en 2012 et le
but c'est de promouvoir la place de la
femme politique en politique et c'est de
les accompagner voilà et de les aider
plus ou moins dans leur bilan dans leur
mandat et dans les Yvelines vous êtes
une des instigatrices de de de
ce collectif dans les Yvelines avec
Salamata bien somatiata qui est élu des
Mureaux vous êtes élu rouge je disais de
la commune de La Verrière parliez de
sensibilisation à la féminisation de la
politique pourquoi c'est important
pourquoi il faut sensibiliser sur le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est très important
aujourd'hui parce que si vous vous êtes
rendu compte depuis quelques temps bien
avant le milieu politique était beaucoup
masculin voilà aujourd'hui les choses
changent il faudrait qu'on change en
même temps et je pense que la part de la
femme est tellement importante moi j'ai
été élu il y a peu avec ma binôme
Salamata et tout de suite je me suis dit
mais c'est tellement important pour nous
de partir tout de suite comme ça pinceau
pour mettre au devant des femmes
politiques des accompagner à mon premier
mandat effectivement il faut être
accompagné il faut savoir comment
s'orienter dans cette vie politique et
susciter l'envie cause pour laquelle
nous lançons ce premier réseau des
Yvelines et ben il en aura d'autres
derrière il y a encore aujourd'hui trop
d'inégalités justement dans la vie
politique entre les femmes et les hommes
tout à fait comme je vous disais les
choses changent je vous donner quelques
chiffres comme ça vite fait nous avons
20% de femmes qui sont maires nous avons
12% de femmes qui sont présidentes
d'intercommunalité donc vous voyez bien
que on a encore loin nous avons 20% de
femmes présidentes de région nous avons
13,8% de femmes présidentes de
département 38% de femmes députés et
31,6% des femmes sénatrices oui
aujourd'hui les choses sont des choses
bougent cause plaquettes nous sommes là
et ce réseau est très important pour
qu'on puisse avoir vraiment beaucoup
plus de femmes si c'était l'envie des
femmes d'aller en politique des choses
changent il y a encore du chemin qui qui
reste-t-il justement aux élus locales
nous sommes près du peuple tout le temps
et c'est important pour nous pour moi
c'est c'est une passion et ça fait
combien de temps vous êtes engagé du
coup mon premier mandat 2020 et avant
enterrement politique en tant que
militante peut-être j'ai militais pas
mais je m'intéressais beaucoup à la vie
politique dans tous les cas la politique
quand on l'a fait pas mais on l'a subi
on l'a vu et moi je l'ai toujours vécu
au quotidien et grâce à Monsieur Nicolas
Dainville on a commencé à faire changer
les choses au niveau de la verrière avec
tous nos projets qui sont en place c'est
ce que Monsieur cite vraiment l'envie de
continuer et d'aller sur d'autres fronts
aujourd'hui donc les femmes c'est facile
de concilier vie professionnelle vie
familiale et vie politique maintenant du
coup c'est une question d'organisation
et de passion quand on est organisé
quand on aime moi je suis maire si vous
avez vu vous avez j'ai fait participer
j'ai invité deux femmes ce sont des
femmes qui m'inspirent deux femmes qui
sont mères dans le 12 communes de
l'agglomération 50 ans Yvelines c'est
pas beaucoup c'est déjà pas mal et ces
femmes ce sont des femmes mères donc
c'est un petit déjeuner que nous avons
fait ce matin déjeuner mère M a I e r e
maire c'est pas facile on peut les
concilier les femmes sont au centre de
tout il y a pas aussi de couleur
politique dans dans ce collectif c'est
transportant comme on l'a dit dès le
départ on vient comme nous sommes
couleur de peau
de partis politiques de bord de religion
peu importe on vient avec des valeurs
nous partageons ces mêmes valeurs c'est
la bienveillance et comment ça se passe
concrètement sur les aides il y a des
groupes de travail comment les élus
viennent vers vous finalement comment se
fait ce contact mais ce contact se fait
comme je fais ce matin c'est un
lancement j'ai demandé à ce que toutes
les femmes élues qu'elle soit un peu
qu'elle soit engagées sur le plan
politique ou pas
qu'on se rencontre qu'on échange nos
différentes expériences et qu'on puisse
accompagner les autres ça reste au
moment de convivialité de partage voilà
c'est comme ça et ça se fait un peu
partout dans chaque commune et voilà sur
le voilà dans les Yvelines c'est
tellement grand on peut être ça se fait
comment ça se fait en raison par
département on a une ambassadrice par
exemple et comme les Yvelines sont
grands on peut être deux donc nous
sommes en binôme voilà
un dernier mot un argument majeur pour
convaincre les femmes à s'engager en
politique
écouter mesdames c'est passionnant quand
on arrive à gérer une famille on peut
gérer
ça collectivité on a bien des femmes en
politique les femmes sont inspirantes on
a plein de modèles autour de nous voilà
c'est vraiment passionnant et j'invite
toutes les femmes à faire comme nous et
surtout de rejoindre ce réseau je
voulais aussi lancer un appel aussi le
25 et 26 novembre prochain nous avons
des journées des femmes élues je
souhaiterais que toutes les femmes
puissent s'inscrire celles qui n'ont pas
été là aujourd'hui il en aura d'autres
on a prévu de faire par trimestre chaque
3 mois de se rencontrer pour déconnecter
un peu et puis il y a des formations
parce qu'il y a des métiers il y a des
délégations qui sont encore très très
valables il y a de l'humanisme des
budgets il y a plein de choses à voir
encore franchement c'est passionnant
j'ai envie de toutes les femmes très
rapidement très rapidement vous parlez
de modèle vous c'est qui votre modèle en
forme politique ce sera le mot de la fin
déjà les deux que j'ai invité ce matin
c'est déjà pas mal ce sont des très
belles femmes de bonne femme et des
femmes inspirantes merci merci
la famille de la petite enfance
conseillère communauté également de 50
ans en Yvelines délégué à l'insertion
professionnelle et vous êtes donc l'une
des instigatrices fondatrices de ce
réseau élu local dans les Yvelines merci
d'être venu pour parler sur ce plateau
l'actualité aussi aujourd'hui c'est le
début de la Coupe du monde de football
c'était même hier puisque le début de
cette coupe du monde était hier avec le
match d'ouverture
Qatar Équateur elle a été lancé
justement dans ce pays au du
Qatar la France elle fera son entrée
demain mardi avec un match face à
l'Australie dans les dernières semaines
la compétition a été vivement critiquée
pour son impact humain écologique le
rappeur et Vinois corta s'est emparé de
cette actualité avec son nouveau titre
Coupe du Monde au Qatar il met en avant
notamment la question ou non du boycott
de ce rendez-vous le clip sorti vendredi
comptabilise déjà plus de 70 000 vues
sur Youtube elle interview de kurta
réalisé avec Gabriel Gontier l'artiste
curta de Montigny-le-Bretonneux revient
avec son nouveau titre Coupe du Monde au
Qatar le clip est sorti la semaine
dernière le son également est justement
pour parler avec nous au kurta bonjour
bonjour ça va ça va très bien merci
alors vous étiez absent des réseaux
alors pas des réseaux mais en tout cas
sur la scène musicale depuis à peu près
un an vous aviez sorti votre dernier
titre il y a à peu près un an un peu
moins d'un an avec quart de siècle là
c'est important pour vous de revenir
avec cet événement qui est la Coupe du
Monde c'est vrai que du coup ça fait des
mois des mois que j'ai que je n'ai rien
sorti et pour mon retour j'avais envie
de marquer le coup un peu avec un
morceau qui on va dire est dans l'air du
temps je vous propose tout de suite
qu'on écoute un extrait de coupe du
monde au Qatar
bon mes coups de Saint-Quentin jusqu'à
la gare de Saint-Lazare mais égaux
façon comme des élans
[Musique]
vous le dites d'emblée dans la musique
c'est un fait d'actu qu'on vient viser
pourquoi choisir ce thème de la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar on sait que c'est un
thème qui fait beaucoup réagir on aura
l'occasion de parler pourquoi mais
pourquoi choisir ce thème alors il y a
plusieurs raisons déjà il faut savoir
que pendant ces longs mois d'absence
j'ai écrit énormément de morceaux j'ai
j'ai beaucoup travaillé entre guillemets
dans l'ombre et il y avait déjà cette
idée de dénoncer un peu cet événement la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar tout simplement
parce que déjà moi j'aime le foot je
suis coach en plus durable et de
l'animation je fais je coach une équipe
féminine à Montigny donc j'aime le foot
et j'ai des je suis je pense comme
beaucoup
gêné d'apprendre malheureusement un peu
tard mais tout l'envers du décor de de
cette Coupe du Monde et puis comme je
suis je pense en tout cas on considère
un peu comme un artiste engagé je
trouvais ça aussi normal de revenir avec
un morceau à la fois un peu égotterie
pour le côté retour et à la fois engagé
pour mes textes à messages parce que
justement vous dites gotrip vous
commencez le premier couplet on a
l'impression que vous faites plaisir
dans ce premier couplet c'était aussi
l'occasion de marquer le coup pour votre
retour c'est ça c'est ça en fait dans
dans le rap et le côté égotep est
toujours est toujours présent et l'idée
c'était de revenir en disant voilà je
suis là malgré mes 10 mois d'absence me
voici en fin de retour et je voulais
prendre les gens à contre-pied avec
pareil ce morceau
ou le titre c'est Coupe du Monde au
Qatar donc de quoi il va parler mais je
voulais en profiter pour dire ça y est
je suis de retour et sur le deuxième
couplet je suis uniquement sur la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar plus censé plus amer
c'est les mots que vous utilisez il y a
des questions dans ce couplet de ces
morts migrants travailleurs qui sont
morts sur les chantiers de la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar 6500 selon un chiffre
révélé par le gardien parle aussi de
l'impact écologique parce que il y a
aussi toute cette question de
l'empreinte carbone de cette Coupe du
monde le monde et selon greening société
il y aurait 6 à 7 millions de tonnes de
CO2 qui seraient consommé pendant cette
Coupe du Monde il y avait plein de
sujets à dénoncer sujet humain sujet
écologique parce que c'est des sujets
d'actualité qui font l'actualité c'est
ça en fait bien évidemment là pour mon
retour ça tombe à ce moment précis on
sort voilà j'ai sorti mon morceau
vendredi la Coupe du monde là c'est
c'est ça a commencé hier donc forcément
c'était un fait d'actualité intéressant
mais au-delà du fait d'actualité même je
trouve que c'est l'un des des l'une des
plus grosses preuves entre guillemets et
malheureusement preuve que que le monde
dans lequel on vit est dictée
malheureusement plus par l'argent que
par ses problèmes parce que c'est pas
nouveau qu'on sait que ça va mal d'un
point de vue environnemental pardon
c'est pas c'est pas depuis hier qu'on
sait que il y a plein de choses à faire
et malheureusement il y a des événements
comme celui-ci donc je trouve que c'est
bien de taper du doigt fin du taper
pardon du point cet événement même si il
y a pas que ça il y a plein de choses
qui faudrait dénoncer mais on est tous
un peu concerné parce que c'est la Coupe
du monde et que même qu'on aime pas le
foot on a toujours un petit œil sur cet
événement
[Musique]
se sont éteint pour pouvoir prier
quelques joueurs j'ai trop la haine
quand là où je suis je peux pas faire
grand-chose suis-je réellement prêt à
passer à côté de ce qu'elle m'a fait va
nous proposer suis-je réellement prêt à
passer à côté de ce que Mbappe va nous
proposer moi je me suis beaucoup
retrouvé pour tout vous dire dans dans
ce passage parce que moi moi-même étant
fan de foot il y a cette question en
tant que fan de foot est-ce qu'on va
regarder cette coupe du monde malgré ce
dont on a parlé est-ce que vous allez
vous la regardez est-ce que vous allez
regarder peut-être les matchs des Bleus
ou justement vous allez vous priver vous
allez boycoter cette coupe du monde
alors soit je fais la réponse MiTo soit
la réponse sincère on veut la réponse
sincère faire non mais je me sens
beaucoup moins concerné par cette Coupe
du monde de plus en plus voilà ce
morceau ça fait déjà plusieurs semaines
qu'il a enregistré j'ai enregistré cet
été
ayant écrit ce morceau je vais pas
suivre la Coupe du monde à 100% même si
le fait qu'on regarde ou qu'on regarde
pas clairement aujourd'hui ça ne change
rien parce que c'est fait c'est fait
donc
maintenant je vais suivre de loin oui
j'ai j'ai envie de savoir quand même ce
que vont faire les Bleus euh mais je me
sens beaucoup moins concernée et moi
c'était une façon c'est pas ce que je
veux dire ce qui est important c'est que
c'est pas un morceau je l'ai pas écrit
que pour pour dire bon tiens je vais
réagir sur sur un fait d'actualité c'est
aussi parce que bah c'est ce que je
pense tout simplement et que et que moi
voilà je suis un petit peu dégoûté de
cet événement je vais suivre de loin
mais vraiment pas autant que que les
Coupes du Monde précédente sur le visuel
d'ailleurs de ce morceau c'est très
épuré on voit la Coupe du Monde on
comprend il y a aussi l'idée de sang
peut-être parce qu'il y a un il y a un
côté rouge et voilà il y a cette couleur
rouge prédominante sur le choix de la
pochette du single on voulait faire
quelque chose de simple et efficace donc
il y a cette Coupe du monde avec
quelques taches de sang derrière je
pense que ça représente bien l'idée du
morceau et la dénonciation qui a
derrière qui retard artiste engagé
artiste engagé aussi dans sa ville
Montigny-le-Bretonneux on est ici au
sein de cette école Paul Verlaine ou
vous travaillez vous le disiez aussi
engagé dans le club de de football et le
clip tournait à Montigny aussi il y a
toujours le petit clin d'oeil à la ville
et avec aussi vos amis les petits jeunes
aussi de Montigny oui alors bon il y en
a qui me disent c'est quand que tu
arrêtes de clipper à Montigny il y a des
clips qui arrivent en Montigny c'est
promis mais c'est vrai que très attaché
à ma ville comme depuis toujours
peut-être des gens qui vont me découvrir
avec ce morceau mais si on apprend un
peu à me connaître c'est pas depuis hier
que j'ai créé des textes engagés c'est
pas depuis hier que je représente
fièrement le département
j'ai toujours ces valeurs en moi et
c'est vrai que Montigny a un petit clin
d'oeil ça a été tourné au stade de la
coude là où je fais les entraînements
effectivement il y a certaines joueuses
que j'entraîne qui sont dans le clip
parce que c'était important pour moi de
mettre en avant le foot entre guillemets
qui vient du peuple le foot féminin
aussi qui se développe énormément et du
coup voilà j'ai ramené les amis les
joueuses et puis on a fait ce clip donc
Coupe du Monde au Qatar qui est on va
dire peut-être le premier jet d'un
retour un peu plus durable avec des
projets qui vont arriver il y a 7 K8 le
deuxième volet de 7 k82 c'est 7 k8b2
même le le nom qui va sortir le 11
décembre c'est ça c'est ça en fait deux
ans jour pour jour après la sortie de
mon premier projet 7 K8 on a du mal
cette qualité 7k 8 2 suite de cette K8
en fait le premier c'est de caviette
était sorti le 11 décembre 2020 avec
notamment le morceau Kery James le
morceau petit que j'avais clippé dans
cette école et là deux ans jour pour
jour donc le 11 décembre sortira cette
cabine 2 avec le morceau Coupe du Monde
au Qatar avec le morceau Omar Sy que
j'avais fait il y a déjà un an et huit
inédits que je vais vous inviter à aller
découvrir le 11 décembre c'est des
morceaux que sur lesquels j'ai vraiment
beaucoup travaillé et qui sont ouverts à
tous il y a de la pop il y a du rap il y
a des messages il y a de quoi s'évader
c'est vraiment un projet
qui ai-je l'espère va vous plaire merci
curta merci de nous avoir accueilli ici
à école Paul Verlaine de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux donc Coupe du
Monde au Qatar votre nouveau titre qui
est sorti tout récemment en pleine Coupe
du Monde qui a démarré hier le match des
Bleus c'est demain face à l'Australie le
titre complet et à retrouver sur les
liens qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
et de la Coupe du monde de football on
en parle encore un petit peu avec vous
Michael et le midoro qui est revenu en
plateau la France fera son entrée demain
dans cette Coupe du Monde ce mardi 22
novembre ce sera à 20h face à
l'Australie quelles sont les communes
dans les Yvelines qui vont diffuser ce
match vous le savez c'est un grand débat
depuis plusieurs semaines certaines
communes ne veulent pas diffuser les
matchs de la Coupe du Monde aussi nos
protestations contre l'organisation au
Qatar les municipalités de trappes et
Andrésy ont par exemple décidé de ne pas
installer à décran géants de diffuser
les matchs mais si on regarde bien très
peu de communes vont organiser un
événement autour de ce premier match des
Bleus j'ai trouvé seulement quatre
villes dans le département qui ont
annoncé sur leur site internet
l'organisation d'une soirée football
pour voir ce premier match des Bleus le
paier en Yvelines dans la salle des
fêtes de la mareulou Bois-d'Arcy à la
Fabrique Bailly à l'espace Robert
Thierry enfin Triel-sur-Seine au Cosec
c'est très peu quand on pense aller
faire les sens autour du premier match
des Bleus lors de la Coupe du Monde 2018
on s'en souvient bien sûr la victoire
des Bleus en plus en finale dans un
instant on se parle de ce tournoi
international de tennis fauteuil qui a
lieu cette semaine à Feucherolles mais
d'abord les résultats sportifs du
weekend et on continue avec du football
justement on jouait ce weekend en coupe
des Yvelines lors de ce 3e tour et en
cours recevait l'équipe de où et qui
évolue une division au dessus malgré une
belle prestation des élans courtois se
sont finalement les joueurs du nord du
département qui se sont qualifiés le
résumé du match regardez il est en cours
contre Houilles une division Descartes
deux équipes pour un objectif se
qualifier en 8e de finale de la Coupe
des Yvelines après seulement quelques
minutes de jeu les eaux-villois en rose
manque l'ouverture du score sur cette
action
un électrochoc pour les élans courtois
qui évoluent en D2 de district ils
prennent le contrôle du jeu et se
procurent les meilleures occasions de
cette première période ils auraient pu
se retrouver en supériorité numérique
mais le gardien de où il ne se fera pas
expulser sur cette action
et récoltera un carton jaune le score la
pose
l'arbitre c'est comme ça il faut
l'accepter
c'est un fait de jeu pour revenir sur
des saisons arbitrales mais pas carton
rouge moi j'ai pas les images donc je
sais pas on s'en sort plutôt bien parce
que ça selon l'interprétation de
certains arbitres si c'est rouge c'est
compréhensible au retour les vestiaires
et l'encours pousse et obtient un
penalty ne sera pas marqué par le numéro
quelques minutes plus tard sur ce centre
le but est refuser aux élans courtois
pour un hors-jeu les bleus et blancs
norés seront pas à marquer c'est
finalement où et qui s'impose grâce à ce
but 1 à 0 ce sera le score final on a vu
que il y avait la place quand même parce
que on a on a on a bien joué on les a on
les a maintenues dans le dans le jeu on
était à leur niveau et on aurait pu on
aurait pu marquer ce but un match de
coupe donc pas facile aujourd'hui malgré
la petite division d'écart qui a entre
les deux clubs après bon sur le match
coupe on sait très bien que ce soit
Coupe de France qu'on peut importe c'est
l'état d'esprit l'envie déjà de vouloir
gagner ce match parce que sur un match
tout est possible direction huitième de
finale pour Houilles le prochain tour de
la coupe des Yvelines est programmé le
dimanche 8 janvier 2023 le tirage au
sort aura lieu le 12 décembre prochain
où et qui pourrait affronter les Mureaux
de lime et Conflans
Montigny-le-Bretonneux molois Chambourcy
auberge en ville ou encore plaisir ce
sont les équipes qualifiées pour le
prochain tour prochain tour donc à venir
dans quelques semaines dans les Yvelines
on parle toujours de football de
championnat national 2 voici repart de
l'avant après trois matchs sans victoire
laisse Poissy dirigée par l’emblématique
président Olivier sevesu qui a gagné ce
samedi soir le club des Vinois s'est
imposé face à la réserve de Caen une
victoire qui fait du bien au classement
les pistes et sont actuellement à la
deuxième place avec 22 points en 10
journées on continue avec la Route du
Rhum Louis Burton le rambolitain a
abandonné mais il reste encore un verset
1 yvelinois en course
Eric Bellion le versaillier est engagé
sur cette édition 2022 dans la catégorie
Moka sur son bateau comme un seul homme
powerhead by Altavia le navigateur de 46
ans est encore à la 22e place du
classement même place que la semaine
dernière il vise un top 15 à la fin de
la course afin de se préparer pour le
prochain Vendée Globe et ça paraît de
plus en plus compliqué il devrait
arriver dans la semaine le premier IMOCA
ce lundi à 7h51 c'était Thomas Royan et
dans la version virtuelle de la Route du
Rhum on est tout proche d'arriver
également dans la rédaction de TV 78
personnellement je vais arriver dans la
nuit entre 3h et 4h du matin je vais
mettre le réveil qui va remporter la
Route du Rhum en rédaction du rugby à
présent nickel dans le championnat de
régional une l'Union rugby 168 à goûter
à la défaite ce dimanche l'équipe c'est
inclinée contre le CO multisport Bagneux
rugby sur le score le 13 à 10 une
défaite qui n'arrange pas et 50 chinois
ils se font dépasser au classement par
leur adversaire du jour et son 4e
égalité après cette journée le basket et
le championnat de National 3 belle
victoire de Trappes ce samedi soir sur
son parquet face à Paris Basket à venir
les Trappistes l'ont emporté 84 à 76
après ce résultat le scrap et 6e du
championnat de National 3 après 10
journées disputés la montée l'objectif
fixé en début de saison va être
compliqué à atteindre on joue également
ce week-end sur les terrains de handball
masculin parce que les féminines sont en
ce moment en trêve avec l'euro en
National trop à plaisir les clés à
réaliser une belle performance ce
dimanche à domicile les joueurs de
Benjamin modeste se sont imposés 28 à 24
devant leur supporter face à l'Union
Sportive Dreux Vernouillet handball de
son côté où il le vésiné carrière c'est
un clinique 33 à 27 façade cher
bourgeoise je mange au classement à
plaisir les clés et 6e et où il le
Vésinet carrière et septième vous
montrer les muscles peut-être pour
terminer ses résultats sportifs ce qu'on
va parler de culturisme
à la participé la semaine dernière au
championnat du monde de culturisme
naturel à Prague en République tchèque
la culturiste de 50 ans a été sacrée
vice championne du monde à deux reprises
et elle a également emporté quatre
médailles de bronze au total sipodium
dans 6 catégories elle est plutôt
satisfaite un de ses résultats même si
la médaille d'or n'est pas au bout bravo
à Muriel bauvillain pour ses résultats
merci Michael on continuera à la suivre
aussi continuer dans cette émission à
parler de sport et de parler plus
précisément de tennis on vous lisez tout
à l'heure le tournoi international BNP
Paris Yvelines Witcher tournament sera
organisé de ce jeudi 24 ce dimanche 27
novembre c'est à Feucherolles dans les
Yvelines alors pour parler de ce tournoi
deux invités sont avec nous ils sont
revenus en plateau leurs moraux qui est
directrice de ce tournoi également
Jean-François et secrétaire
général du Comité des Yvelines de tennis
vous en parler un peu tout à l'heure
pourquoi organiser un tournoi
international de tennis fauteuil mais
tout simplement parce que le comité des
Yvelines est engagé dans des différentes
actions sociétales et typiquement le
paratellis est notamment le tennis en
fauteuil on fait partie on est en plus
centre d'entraînement pour ce qu'on
appelle le groupe la relève Paris 2024
où on a des athlètes à la phare tels que
Pauline Déroulède Olivier Langlois ou
Anthony Bocquet qui sont en plus des non
seulement ce sont des Franciliens mais
surtout des vicinois donc voilà ça ça
l'intérêt pour nous bien sûr de mettre
en avant le département et donc au-delà
du haut niveau
[Musique]
sur le puisqu'il y aura du simple et du
double et c'est très spectaculaire de
voir de la manière ou ils évoluent sur
nos installations pour compléter ce que
disait alors effectivement ce nous avons
souhaité organiser ce type de tournoi ça
va dans le prolongement dans notre
structure d'entraînement dit la relève
ou Pauline Anthony et s'entraîne tous
les jours comité il faut savoir que
c'est la seule structure en France c'est
unique notre structure et ça va leur
c'est on les prépare pour Paris 2024
puisqu'ils ont un objectif de Paris 2024
avec Pauline effectivement qui est faire
de lance de notre structure et ce genre
de tournoi les aides dans leur
préparation pour l'objectif Paris 2024
on peut parler d'un tournoi de de
préparation pour ces Jeux paralympiques
Jeux Olympiques je paralympiques qui
vont arriver qui sont dans toutes les
têtes c'est vraiment une préparation
tout à fait dans leur dans leur
préparation ils ont encore deux ans pour
pour évoluer mais ça fait partie de de
d'une préparation effectivement pour
parler 2024 pour nos trois athlètes tous
les étrangers justement viennent dans
dans les Yvelines pour préparer ces Jeux
Olympiques c'est Jeux paralympiques de
2024 qui viennent pour préparer
spécifiquement les jeux je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas
cas d'évolu dans dans les mêmes tournois
donc il y avait un tournoi l'Open du
Loiret la semaine dernière il y a pas
mal de joueurs qui ont participé à cette
open qu'on va retrouver à Feucherolles
la semaine enfin cette semaine donc
voilà c'est un mine de rien microcosme
les athlètes surtout chez des filles
sont sont moins nombreuses effectivement
donc elle se connaissent toutes il y a
certaines revanche à prendre mais je
pense que le titre devrait être français
quand même chez les chez les messieurs
et chez les femmes cette année en tout
cas on l'espère ce serait est-ce que
vous avez pu échanger avec Pauline des
roulettes dans quel état d'esprit
est-elle alors la tire la lumière sur ce
tournoi mais ce qu'elle est venue aussi
pour pour le remporter on imagine que
oui bah oui bien sûr
comme elle disait exactement en fait
elle joue à la maison donc c'est vrai
que elle s'est posée la question avec sa
coach de participer ou non à ce tournoi
là et pour elle évidemment il n'était
pas question qu'elle soit absente de
cette de ce tournoi donc on aura le
plaisir de avec nous et de et de l'avoir
joué vous la sentez progresser
Jean-François Mettet Pauline Déroulède
de tournoi en tournoi d'année en année
bien sûr puisque bon
3 ans qu'elle s'est mis
pour par son accident elle s'est
retrouvé donc en fauteuil et bien sûr
puisque maintenant les numéros en
français ça fait deux ans de suite
qu'elle gagne le championnat de France
oui elle a une progression elle est
partie de de nos enfin de vierge de ce
de cette de ce sport et aujourd'hui
numéro 1 française les temps forts bon
il y aura les matchs forcément du 24 au
27 il y a le tirage au sort pour
commencer c'est un peu le l'événement
pour lancer officiellement le tournoi
tirage au sort vendredi soir voilà avec
on espère des belles affiches annoncées
ensuite mercredi évidemment accueille
aussi de la plupart des joueurs alors
certains sont déjà arrivés d'autres
arriveront uniquement mercredi d'autres
vont encore arriver jeudi très tôt avant
le début de la compétition donc c'est
toute une organisation qui représente
essentiellement sur des bénévols et
quelques salariés mais c'est aussi un
message important c'est que le
langagement bénévole prend tout son sens
aussi dans l'organisation de ce type
d'événement on est à peu près 20
bénévoles à
œuvrer aux côtés des de salariés du
comité et c'est vraiment un temps fort
dans la vie dans la vie du bénévole dans
la saison dans la saison sportive donc
ce tournoi est-ce que c'est gratuit
est-ce qu'il faut prendre ces places à
l'avance comment ça comment ça se passe
et vous serez tous et bienvenue et un
dernier mot peut-être pour parler des
autres événements pas les autres grands
événements à venir pour le comité de
tennis des Yvelines alors un événement
qui nous tient à cœur aussi ça sera donc
le dernier week-end de janvier où nous
allons organiser puisque ça fait deux
années de suite malheureusement qui sont
c'est annulés suite à la crise sanitaire
et donc on a de nouveau l'organisation
de la ce qu'on appelle la Wilton Cup
championnat d'Europe pour les jeunes
filles de 12 ans qui auront lieu donc
avec une nation dont la France et donc
c'est aussi un événement qui nous tient
à cœur et que nous allons organiser donc
ça sera le dernier week-end de septembre
un dernier mot Michel peut-être oui
est-ce que ce tournoi international que
vous allez organiser va s'inscrire aussi
dans le temps il y a une première
édition cette année mais est-ce que vous
voulez l'accueillir l'année prochaine et
encore dans 10 ans peut-être alors tout
à fait c'est même on est même un peu
ambitieux mais bon c'est le propre des
sportifs c'est de vouloir aller toujours
plus loin et donc pour nous l'idée c'est
de se développer aussi et de monter dans
la hiérarchie des tournois
internationaux évidemment pour cela ben
ça nécessitera d'autres soutien alors on
a des beaux soutiens aujourd'hui un abnp
Paribas évidemment nos instances de
tutelles d'autres partenaires privés
mais l'organisation d'un tournoi de
grade supérieure nécessitera aussi
d'aller chercher d'autres d'autres
partenaires voilà donc à suivre
Merci à VOUS Laure me remercier
Jean-François Mettet d'être venu parler
de ce tournoi international de tennis
fauteuil qui a lieu donc de ce jeudi à
ce dimanche c'est à Feucherolles bien
sûr dans les Yvelines avant de vous
laisser et de refermer ce 7 8 un dernier
coup d'oeil par la météo
grisaille demain dans les Yvelines avec
peut-être les villes doudans et de
Rambouillet qui seront épargnés par la
pluie le matin il fera en moyenne entre
6 et 7 degrés quelques éclaircies
peut-être dans l'après-midi mais avec de
la pluie fera 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 9 degrés à Versailles
ou dans les Rambouillet ce mardi 22
novembre nous fêterons les céciles c'est
la fin du 7 8 merci de votre fidélité
merci Michael m'avoir accompagné merci à
cette deuxième partie d'édition sur
cette partie sport et le 7 8 qui revient
bien sûr demain on parlera notamment de
l'ouverture de la campagne d'hiver des
Restos du Coeur belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]